I'm Rose Byrne and I'm suffering I'm
Rose Byrne and I'm Seth Rogen we are
doing the Google autocomplete interview
we nailed it
is Seth Rogen best friends with James
Franco oh that's a nice question we're
really really good friends is he my best
friend he's one of my best friends sure
one of my best friends is that throwing
in related to Joe Rogan that's the
stupidest question because our babes are
almost the same
Waka Flocka blunt roller okay there's a
rapper named waka flocka flame who was
looking for a professional blunt roller
and I mentioned that I could do that for
timing didn't work out so the answer is
no I am NOT Waka Flocka flames actual
blunt roller
people Barbra Streisand that's a very
that's a borderline anti-semitic
question just got a remote famous Jewish
people does I did play your side of the
movie no I'm not her son okay in Seth
Rogen's high on sets sometimes you know
they're not always you know they're not
it's not only Shakespearean passionate
Spike you did not I swear they found
passion in Shakespeare's play very
recently maybe write some good stuff
right there you know what that's that's
that's why an accent it'd be amazing if
you did it the answer is yes I was born
in another country called Australia this
is how they sound
I skate i dude this is where I leave you
where I play an ice skating instructor
oh I do actually I speak really
double everything that's been chasing um
a little bit little bit major motion
picture Eddie
exactly everyone has incredible success
have curly hair I do you do don't say it
like that
embrace your curls and press it a lot
guts don't Seth Rogen play World of
Warcraft no but I get why you would
think I would have tattoos in the movie
for over j'en I played a guy with a lot
of tattoos a lot of the crew I remember
was very disappointed because they
thought they were real and then they
learned they were not like oh you're
just a nerdy Jewish guy not a cool guy
with hunter tattooed Rogen have an Oscar
yeah I just keep it in my bathroom you
know I just yeah it's not a big deal you
know it is Rosberg Australian we've
talked we've been through this and it's
true we need your papers rose where's
your birthday today isn't he
Irish or Scottish yeah well sir so he's
from somewhere in the Celtic land yeah
we have this wait not related sadly he's
ruining the movie Troy yeah
yes he is you're Brad Pitt's love slave
yes you're kind of stuck in a tent tied
up love slave another bird is really
baby bird
no but I met him at a party like two
weeks ago that's when I totally
embarrassed myself and I said same name
a nice person yes obviously you could
tell from this interview this is
unfiltered roseburg all right
we hate Family Guy no Seth MacFarlane
created Family Guy
did Seth Rogen groped neighbors hi
I did not know the first neighbors I did
wrote I co-wrote in that context - yes I
co-wrote neighbors - yeah definitely go
to college no Seth Rogen did not
graduate from high school but Seth Rogen
go to college sounds like a good name
for hilarious film did Seth Rogen and
James Franco kiss I have kissed James
Franco for for comedic purposes yeah I
don't want to say that it's only been
for comedy yeah it's also been for
feelings so yes I've been Seth Rogen and
I am not related to Joe Rogan this has
been Google auto-fill questions right
great